[ROCKET BLAST OFF]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
At Google I/O 2017
we opened the door to
Room, a persistence
library that provides an
abstraction layer over SQ Lite.
Now, Room has reached version
2.0 and is part of Jetpack.
We fixed the bugs you reported,
and added some of the features
you asked for.
Let's go over Room's
main components
and see what queries
are supported,
how to implement
migrations, and how to test
your work with the database.
Let's say that you want
to have a table of users,
and you want every
row of that table
to be an instance
of the user class.
Annotate your class
with that entity.
Define the table
name if you don't
want to use the
name of the class
as tableName, set the
mandatory primary key,
and the optional column info.
But only if you want to
change the name of the column.
Otherwise the
field name is used.
And that's it.
Room will take care of the
creation of the user table
for you.
So that's how the
entity is done.
But we need a way to access
the data in the database.
We do that with data access
objects, DAOs for short.
More precisely,
create an interface.
Annotate it with @Dao.
In this interface
declare all the methods
needed to work
with the database,
annotating them with the
corresponding SQL query.
Room takes care of implementing
these methods for you.
The supported queries are
insert, update, delete, query,
and rawquery.
All of them except
rawquery are checked
at compile time, which
means that if you
write an invalid query, you'll
find this out immediately.
The class that puts together
the entities and the DAOs
is the room database.
Create an extra class that
extends the Room database.
Annotate it.
Declare the entities and
the corresponding DAOs.
Let's take a closer
look at the queries.
The return type of
query and rawquery
can be the entire entity, but
also a subset of its fields.
If you're working with
Guava or with Optional
from the Java util
package, you can also
use them as return types.
So this means that if
there are no values
to satisfy your
query, then your query
will return Optional.empty
or Optional.absent,
depending on which Optional
you're working with.
All of these queries
are synchronous,
meaning that they will
be run on the same thread
that you are
triggering them from.
Room ensures you follow best
practices by throwing an error
if you run queries
on the main thread.
So use your preferred method
of handling threads in Android,
and make sure you are
off the main thread.
Room also supports
asynchronous query
when working with
LiveData or RXJava.
What's more, the queries
that return LiveData,
or [? flowable, ?] are
observable queries,
meaning that you will
get notified every time
the data in the table,
or tables, updates.
Whenever you alter your
database schema, either
because you've added or
renamed a column or a table,
you need to tell the database
how to handle that change.
In order to do that
in your database class
you'll need to first update
your database version.
Second, implement
a migration class,
which defines how to handle the
migration from the old schema
to the new one.
And then, thirdly, add
that migration class
as a parameter to
the database filter.
After triggering
the migrations, Room
validates the schema for you to
ensure that the migration was
done correctly.
If you don't want to
handle migrations,
and you don't need to
preserve your database data,
call
fallbacktodestructivemigrations
when building the database.
To destructively
recreate the database
only from a specific
version on, call
fallbacktodestru
ctivemigrationfrom.
And provide the number
for that version.
So we have our entities, DAOs,
database, and migrations.
How do we test that?
To test the DAOs, you'll need
to implement an Android JUnit
test that creates an
in-memory database.
The in-memory database
holds the data
only for as long as
the process is alive,
meaning that after every test,
the database is destroyed.
To test asynchronous queries,
use an instanttaskexecutorrule
to execute each
task synchronously.
In your app's
implementation, you'll
end up referencing the
DAOs in other classes.
To unit test those
classes, just mock the DAO
or implement the fake version.
Here's another tip.
To implement Espresso
tests, covering
code that uses
asynchronous queries,
extend the
countingtaskexecutorrule
to count the tasks as
they start and finish.
Finally, don't forget
to test the migrations.
Explore the database
schema first,
and then use another handy test
rule, the migrationtesthelper.
This class allows you to
create the database in an older
version, and run and
validate each migration.
All you need to do is
check that the data
you inserted in
the older version
is also present
after the migration.
OK.
So let's summarize this.
Less boilerplate code.
Compile-time checked queries.
Ease of implementing migrations.
A high degree of testability.
And checks for
keeping the database
work away from the main thread.
All of these
qualities of Room make
it easier and more pleasant to
work with databases, helping
you deliver better apps.
[ROCKET BLASTING OFF]